so were you an anime fan or anything as
well well i used to watch i used to
watch anime way beckons a day
i would have to say um i've seen i've
seen a lot
from let's see maybe like 2010s
i would say but the most recent anime
that i've really enjoyed is i think
i i really liked dr stone i've mentioned
dr stone i really liked maiden abyss so
those were the two that i was really
into
um we know that we know the guy who did
the the soundtrack to me
really you know
[Applause]
he's just he's just this really aussie
block
yeah you you won't be amazed if you ever
meet him in real life oh yeah
yeah i mean i kind of thought the dr
stern anime was mid there i said it
thought it was mediocre oh that's okay i
can totally understand that i don't
really know why i enjoyed it i think
that my my method of like thought at
that time was
i haven't watched anime in a long time
let's just watch something this guy has
a head that looks like a piece of celery
let's just go into it
and i checked it out and i i really
liked the main character he made me
laugh a lot he has like
a personality that i enjoy um and
yeah i mean i think the characters are
fine but um
i don't know what it was i think i think
i just it was a nice comfy show that i
could sit back and not really care it
was it was definitely coming
i think because everyone was hyping it
up as like the next big
isn't that just what happened it's
really it's really weird why because i
think i i think the thing i
didn't like about it was the shonen side
yeah the fact that it was like a
typical shonen jump anime and what i
didn't like was when they had like these
arbitrary battles and stuff like that
like i saw the tournament arc and it was
the first time i was like
why is there a tournament yeah please
please get rid of the tournament
that was so bad it was like just get
back to the science
we want the science whenever they were
just inventing stuff like
that scene where um they invented the
light bulb
[ __ ] [ __ ] brilliant scene yeah
that was awesome
like when they're fighting i'm like get
this get the [ __ ] out of me i i think as
well there might have been like at least
in japan there might have been like a
prior hype
to it because it was written by the same
guy did i shield 21. right
right like oh [ __ ] this is the guy who
wrote i shall 21 so must be just as good
as i shield 21. and then you're watching
you're like
but you also mentioned 2010's anime yeah
like a few favorites you could list off
i think i remember from your debut
stream you said you really like madoka
magica right yes really
oh wow yeah 100 big fan oh can we call
madoka magic at classic now
is it that's all i think so that's
awesome 20 2011 i think
so far so far not trash taste what else
is on the list i wonder
my number one favorite show of all times
it has it has to be gurren lagann
that is a classic that's a classic it
was one of my first actually
anime that i really washed and and loved
so was that like the anime that you'd
say
yes i would say well because i had
watched a couple before um that my
friends
uh in reaper school had recommended to
me for example um like i
watched of course inuyasha was just on
tv of course so i watched that and then
full metal alchemist as well i watched
that
and i enjoyed um but i still thought
that and i was like okay anime is kind
of cool you know i i drew it a little
bit
but i didn't really get into it until i
watched girl logon and i was like this
made me feel
something that i didn't feel before
that's crazy i love it
and maybe anime is like this cool
awesome i'm gonna keep watching it
uh and still to this day we wouldn't see
anything like that for a very long time
exactly
exactly yeah i just yeah i just checked
miraculous 2011. so i i'd say almost 10
years almost 10 years
at this point which is [ __ ] [ __ ] like
i just i just remember what
magical girls were like before madoka
magicka and now like every magical girl
i see
uh it's like it's like an edgelord it's
like an edgelordfest show yeah exactly
exactly
yeah remember when people were like damn
revolutionary girl uttana is so edgy
and then it's like oh [ __ ] never mind
monica monkey has like people actually
dying
yeah exactly did you like like how
deep were you into it like did you watch
like the movies and stuff i haven't seen
those yet actually i remember
i i was all that i remember exactly
because it was a while ago i was
on the internet while it aired and i
experienced that whole thing
i guess that's what i can say about that
because it was pretty like [ __ ]
inescapable when it first yeah yeah yeah
it's like that everyone i don't think i
was watching anime when it came out
really
i haven't gotten into anime at that
point so i never experienced that so you
you never like experienced like the
golden age right like the mid-2000s
i guess i didn't i guess i did what is
your golden age connor
what do you mean i got into it like 2013
i think and that's when i really like
watched a [ __ ] up that was like when i
every single day was like 12 episodes oh
that's that's
god i miss those days so yeah you have a
binge anime like that as well
oh yeah for sure for sure yeah you would
just watch any shitty
12 episode anime you could find out yeah
like and and you're like oh it's strong
episodes yeah i don't know what it is i
was like oh the summer season has
a 27 series new series yeah i got time
no problem
and now i'm like a 20-minute episode get
the [ __ ] out of my life i feel like
that's so you can tell who like a new
anime fan is when they can actually
watch anything i'm like what's wrong
with you
i find it so weird right because it's my
mentality with watching content has like
changed so much where
do you know what i mean where sometimes
a 20-minute anime episode just seems
like such hard work
and then i see like a two-hour youtube
video or like a [ __ ] three-hour vichy
which
it'll is like it'll be 20 minutes of
like super highly produced million
dollar budget and then on youtube be
like
two hours speed run of uh mario's nipple
yeah yeah
which one do you choose dude mario
nipple percentage for sure
every time man like really it was really
interesting actually is that um back in
the day
i used to be able to watch a lot more
anime because
i've always been very busy i've always
been a very very busy
being right except back in the day i
didn't have a problem uh
watching dubs because i could do my work
and i could listen
but things have changed so are you just
like
person now or it's it's not a hard no on
all dubs
yeah it's not a hard no do you have a
dub that you like but
uh yes i feel like that's a classic lake
of course
i never said that was bad
there's so many okay there's so many
[ __ ] on the red and who are
like wow joey thinks the bok hunter dub
is bad i'm like
no [ __ ] i never said that better
than this i just think the sub is also
good
that's fair as well i'll i'll let you
tell me a little thank you guys you're
my favorite guest so far
yeah yeah i mean i i don't i don't want
to ever be one of those people that's
like
no dubs because that that really kind of
just puts
like that really kind of puts a damper
on all the hardware yeah joey's yeah
joey's got that unlocked down here
[Music]
joey's like as a professional japanese
person
as a professional as a professional
japanese voice actor
let me just pull out my resume yeah i
don't need to watch that i'm sorry for
interrupting you
no no you're fine it's okay the thing is
at the end of the day there's also
the fact that just because you work hard
on something doesn't mean that it's good
so it's harsh it's harsh that's what i
say to myself i only say it because
that's what i say to myself
every day just because you work hard on
something doesn't mean that it's going
to be good and it doesn't mean that it's
going to be high quality voice actors
just like pointing out the other one
like
listen to the entire [ __ ]
industry i'm not even a voice actor
please don't come after me please
this is about anything not just voice
acting it's about anything that anyone
does listen please the other people was
just like if you suck you suck
i don't know what to tell you i say it
to you because i say it to me i think
more people need to hear that yeah
advice from cali
uh how about you just don't suck um